[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
a special prosecutor tapped for the
so-called doomsday cult couple case
why the appointment only applies to chad
day bell and not laurie valodebel's
prosecution
for now the boulder supermarket mass
shooting 10 victims identified
including a police officer the suspect
charged with 10 counts of murder
we will hold the evildoer responsible
to the full extent of the law actor
armie hammer accused
of raping a woman and slamming her head
against a wall
the accuser speaking out about what she
says was a four-hour long attack
i feel immense guilt for not speaking
out sooner plus
the jury now seated in the trial of
derek shovin our expert analysis
as the first officer charged with
murdering george floyd goes to trial
we're being a little bit naive when we
ask people to put
everything to the side law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
[Music]
coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
the people who will decide the fate of
the former officer
accused of murdering george floyd have
been selected law and crimes kim johnson
is in minneapolis
and is here to tell us why one of those
jurors could still be cut
brian a jury is fully seated in derrick
shovin's trial attorneys and the judge
agreed on a
final juror a white man in his 20s who
works
as an accountant he said that he
supports police
but didn't think four officers needed to
respond to a counterfeit bill call
and also said derrick chauvin kneeling
on george floyd's neck for
five to ten minutes seemed unnecessary
here he is
defense attorney eric nelson questioning
him about that
and ultimately you also remember that
the initial autopsy said george floyd
did not die from suffocation but a
different
autopsy came to a different conclusion
the question being is
you may or may not hear evidence about
different medical opinions
based on your role as a juror can you
set aside everything that you may have
heard
beforehand and focus exclusively on the
evidence that
as it's presented in court yes
of the 15 jurors seated in derrick
shovin's trial
six are people of color nine are white
nine of the jurors are women and six are
men now 12 jurors and two alternates
will be sworn in on monday
judge peter cahill said the whole point
of a 15th alternate
juror is in case any of the 14 have to
be dismissed or excused before
that now judge cahill also said that he
plans to release the entire jury pool
after the 14 our sworn in opening
statements begin
monday at 9 00 a.m brian thanks kim
and as jury selection comes to a close
we ask psychologists and law and crime
expert dr john de la torre
if we can really expect jurors to be
fair and impartial once testimony in
children's trial begins
i think we're being a little naive i i
think that
for the most part people can put sort of
the weight
of the information to the side but they
can't put the information to the side
because as soon as they start hearing
evidence as soon as they start hearing
the cases being presented
it's automatically going to trigger all
of the memories all of the
information that they had already had in
their brain and you have to
already be in a mindset to know that
what you've been exposed to
is such a limited amount of information
i think that will be
key in sort of both uh thematically
both cases that are going to be
presented which are there is so much
more that you need to know
you only got a small bit and only those
people who are
open-minded to hear and can look and
self-reflect and know that i only know a
little bit
i need to know more in order to make a
decision that's the kind of people you
want
joining us today is civil rights
attorney and managing party partner
at the cochran firm brian dunn and terry
austin
brian the jury is set but one will be
cut before the trial starts
what do you think of the jury so far and
only having two alternates
well one of the things that we have to
understand brian is that this has never
happened before
the video that we've seen is completely
unprecedented the racial dynamics that
are bringing
uh that are brought up are unique but
this has never happened before
and when you start looking at the makeup
of the jury you start to consider the
fact that there are millions and
millions of people watching everything
that's happening in that tiny courtroom
this makeup seems to go over the top in
terms of reflecting the diversity of the
county and the nation
they seem to be understanding that this
is a very public situation
in a private area and when you're
talking about the 15th juror
what the people need to understand is
that those two alternates are not going
to do anything unless something happens
to one of the original 12.
the problem is if you run out of more
than two of them
you're going to be left without a juror
i strongly disagree with the idea of
letting that 15th jury go brian
i would as well terry the demographics
as brian touched on
of the jury is way more diverse than the
county city and state
the trial is in right now right wow yeah
that's right there's no question about
it i mean we know that we have to give
tobin a fair
and impartial jury under the sixth
amendment but right now we know that the
jury is 60
white twenty six percent black and
thirteen percent multi-racial
that's compared to henneman county which
is seventy four percent white
fourteen black and three percent
multi-racial
now the numbers are different but i
don't think those numbers are
really the issue i think the issue is
what did you think about that video and
whether or not you could be
fair and impartial so i think that's the
crucial issue here brian
yeah at the end of the day it's not the
color of the skin of the jurors who's
making the decision
it's the evidence being presented in
their mindset there be sure to tune in
to the law and crime network for gavel
to gavel coverage of the derrick chauvin
trial in the murder of george floyd
still ahead on law and crime daily a
special homicide attorney is added to
one of the so-called doomsday
couple's case but not the other yet but
first
the allegations of sexual assault and
the criminal investigation
into army hammer the kinky accusations
he is claiming were consensual
next
[Music]
welcome back more allegations of sexual
abuse are being made against actor armie
hammer
and now the lapd is investigating law
and crimes angenette levy is here with
one woman's story
and the high-powered lawyer representing
her
brian this latest accuser says that army
hammer essentially tortured her and that
she feared he might kill her
but the lawyer for army hammer says the
woman's allegations of abuse
simply are not true i met army hammer
on facebook in 2016 when i was 20 years
old
i fell in love with him instantly but
the woman only identified as effie says
the relationship took a dark turn
effie has a photo of herself with hammer
she says he became
emotionally sexually and physically
abusive raping her at one point for four
hours
he beat my feet with a crop so they
would have heard whatever step i took
for the next week during those four
hours
i tried to get away but he wouldn't let
me we all should avoid victim
shaming and victim blaming famed women's
rights attorney gloria allred represents
effie
it is important to emphasize that even
if a sexual partner
agrees to certain sexual activity she
still has a right
at any point to withdraw her consent
whether the activity was consensual is
the key question
hammer's attorney andrew breitler shared
this instagram screen grab with law and
crime
in which he says effie stated i'm not
saying he raped me
and in january of this year she typed i
didn't say anywhere
it was not consensual butler goes on to
say that all of hammer's
sexual encounters have been consensual
and he actually provided us with a text
message that he says effie sent to army
hammer
in which she appeared to be the
aggressor and hammer actually rejected
her advances
the lapd would only confirm that army
hammer is the named suspect in an
alleged sexual assault
allegation that was filed with the
police department back in early february
brian thanks aunt jeanette here to
discuss the allegations against actor
armie hammer and civil rights attorney
brian dunn and terry austin
terry statue limitations or the age of
the case not likely a problem here
for the prosecution but what about that
text from hammer's lawyer
those texts look really damaging to me
because that's the crux of the case
was this consensual or not she's
claiming
that while some of her encounters were
consensual
there were several that were not if in
fact these text messages
are talking about those instances
and saying that they were consensual
then that is really going to hurt her
case
and it's going to support his case and
technology
will be a part of this and all that
evidence is going to come in so
i think that it boils down to he said
she said and what the evidence is going
to support
brian jeffrey epstein harvey weinstein
bill cosby these cases
have redefined sexual assault
prosecution with what you know so far
could army hammer be next on that list
the reason why i wouldn't put him in
that category brian is he hasn't
achieved in life as much as those people
have achieved
he hasn't achieved the level of
notoriety that would cause him to fall
as to
as precipitously as a bill cosby or
harvey weinstein
but nevertheless the idea that we have a
situation where
there is a very serious allegation of
very
serious uh serious misconduct torture
rape we have to look at it broader than
just these two players
and think about how it is that we can
expand our consciousness towards
the idea of date rape and the things
that people do in the privacy of their
own
home having very long you know long-term
consequences
exactly now angela what's the fallout
been for army hammer so far
yeah the fallout's been pretty
significant so far his publicist has
dropped him he's also lost out on
several projects some film projects and
it's not just from this specific
allegation from effie she's saying this
occurred back in 2017.
this all started back when some women
started posting on social media about
hammer's alleged sexual fetishes it's
interesting to see how this plays out as
you all have pointed out there i think
there's more investigation
that's needed here to find out what the
truth is
as i said earlier the lapd is
investigating we will keep tabs on
whether or not a criminal case starts up
i know a civil one hasn't started yet
but you better believe that one will be
close
to that of the criminal case thank you
everyone coming up on law and crime
daily a judge adds a special homicide
prosecutor to chad
davao's case is she merely there to help
or is this a sign of things to come
plus a supermarket in boulder colorado
is struck by tragedy
in a mass shooting killing 10 people a
suspect in custody and a city mourns
[Music]
next
we're back a suspect in a deadly mass
shooting at
a colorado grocery store is now charged
with 10 counts of murder
shots rang out monday afternoon at the
king's super grocery store in boulder
by the end of the rampage 10 people were
killed officers arrived on the scene
within minutes and immediately
entered the store and engaged the
suspect
there was this exchange of gunfire which
such was shot
the suspect identified as 21-year-old
ahmad al-isa
taken to the hospital with a wound to
his leg he's expected to be processed
into the boulder county jail
the district attorney says the motive
for the shooting is still unknown
but local state and federal law
enforcement are investigating
in terms of terms of statements that he
may have made to investigators first
i want to stress that he's innocent
unless and until proven guilty of course
as we do in every case but more
importantly we're collecting those
statements now we'll be providing those
in the weeks ahead
10 victims range in age from 20 to 65.
officer eric talley identified as one of
the fallen police say tally was the
first officer to arrive
at the grocery store and call his
actions
had seven heroic ages five to 18.
i just had that officer's whole family
in my office two weeks ago
to give him an award officer tally's
patrol vehicle parked outside the police
station
in memory of his sacrifice
back with us as civil rights attorney
brian dunn and co-host terry austin
colorado has unfortunately seen mass
shootings and their prosecution in the
past
james holmes got 12 life sentences
without parole plus over 3 000 years in
jail for the murder of 12 and injuring
70 others in a movie screening of the
dark knight in 2012.
with that being said brian do what's
your reaction to this
shooting and what do you expect of the
prosecution in this case
well one of the important things that
you were bringing up earlier brian is
the concept of the death penalty because
that's
the kind of thing that a crime like this
is going to resonate with people are
going to want to know
is this man going to get the death
penalty colorado has abolished that
this is going to be a swift
administration of very severe justice
and he is never going to get out of
prison but the deeper issue brian is
why does this keep happening exactly
terry as brian said
colorado abolished the death penalty
march 23rd of 2020 becoming the 22nd
state
to do so so knowing that what do you
foresee in this kind of case
well you know i think that like brian
said this is a
very difficult case and why does it keep
happening
look i think my heart clearly goes out
to those
innocent families and you know whether
the individual convicted is in jail for
the rest of his life or
faces the death penalty i think the real
issue here
is one are we helping those individuals
who need psychological help
and two what are we doing as far as gun
control
is concerned there's so much more that
we need to do to help
keep weapons of mass destruction out of
the hands of individuals
and two to just make sure that people
who
are getting background checks who show
signs of issues
do not receive guns so there's so much
more that we can do here brian
obviously a number of issues in the
backdrop when it comes to
how uh this individual got a gun how
they were able to
to to create such damage and of course
as we said
in colorado this has happened uh more
than once you can even go back to 1999
with the columbine shooting in the high
school there in uh in in colorado that's
well within my lifetime
as many people who are viewing this
again our thoughts and prayers goes out
to those injured in their families
and we'll keep eyes on this case as the
prosecution continues when we come back
the addition of a missouri prosecutor
who's handled over a hundred homicide
cases
to one of the suspects charged in the
doomsday cult couple case
what it could mean for chad dabo next
[Music]
welcome back the prosecution team for
the so-called doomsday cult couple is
growing
law on crime's terry austin is here to
tell us about the unusual twist
in the chad day bell and laurie daybell
case
brian a special prosecutor has been
appointed in chad dabel's case
but not yet in his wife lori balodebel's
case
the reason for the split isn't entirely
clear
this is a very complicated case
complicated is how prosecutor rob wood
described the case of a so-called
doomsday cult couple
lori valo and her husband chad dabell
are facing charges for an alleged plot
to conceal and destroy evidence
while valo's children were reported
missing authorities discovered the
bodies of jj and tyler ryan
buried in shallow graves on daebel's
property the amount of discovery
as we've talked about is is it's very
very large there's a lot of information
homicide charges have not been filed in
the deaths of valo's children
but wood is asking for assistance from
missouri attorney
rachel smith smith is a 25-year veteran
homicide and death penalty prosecutor
and worked at the missouri attorney
general's office
we're seeking to have her help on this
case
through the madison county prosecutor's
office appointed to special prosecutor
woods says appointing smith to the day
bell case
allows him to focus on other pending
cases
in his jurisdiction chad day bell's
defense did not object to her
appointment
but wanted to make sure the proper
courts are consulted
he does not get to enlarge
retain someone and say you're going to
handle all of my cases
you're going to train my staff and
you're going to teach us how to process
properly prosecute cases
that's not something that he's
prevented from doing but in this
particular case he's prevented from
having ms
smith participate unless fremont county
gives them their blessing the day bells
are charged in fremont county
where chad's property is located wood is
the prosecuting attorney in madison
county
and was appointed as special prosecutor
of the day bells case in fremont
woods says madison county will be
covering the cost
of smith's involvement i maintain a law
practice primarily
involving special prosecutions i am a
special prosecutor
or an appointed prosecutor assisting at
least
two counties in the state of missouri i
also consult
both on legal matters and on legal
training for multiple
other jurisdictions noticeably silent
during the hearing
was mark means lori valo dabel's
attorney
according to east idaho news that's
because of a sealed
court order suspending all upcoming
hearings
for lori valodebel the hearing started
out with nearly
30 minutes in a breakout session then
the judge announced the hearing would
only be chad day bell
and the court would reserve ruling on
the issue for lori balodebel
miss smith can be admitted but in order
to be
on the case would need to either be a
deputy of your office or part of your
office
in the end judge boyce approves smith's
admission
the next hearing on the day bell case is
scheduled for april 7th
ryan thanks terry brian what do you make
of the prosecution's request
for rachel smith specifically they went
halfway across the country
to find a homicide prosecutor it's like
saying hey lebron james going to play on
my team but he's just going to stand
here right
what do you think it means your hunch is
correct brian they're going for
the big charges here they have actually
gone to the trouble of getting
a prosecutor that's out of their
jurisdiction
and they're doing this because one of
the elephants in the room brian is that
careers of prosecutors rise and fall on
these high-profile cases
there can't afford to take any chances
at all
and the idea that you have a very strong
woman going after the woman in this case
there is some imagery there because
people don't usually associate women
with homicides
in this case it's going to be different
exactly
i think it's going to be a very big case
like you said i don't know if this
county has had such a big case they
definitely want to make sure they have
the big guns
to match the severity and the
seriousness of this case terry
what about lori valo's case do you think
rachel smith will be added to that case
as well
i think eventually she will be
technically
judge boyce did not want to go out of
his range his jurisdiction is over his
courtroom in fremont
county in connection with chad dabo but
i do
think that because the judge admitted
rachel smith prohawk vichy
to help prosecutor wood as long as he
deputizes smith and i think once that
happens
once she gets involved in the case once
she begins to help out
and frankly i think she's going to help
with strategy here
so i do think that ultimately she might
actually
be helping out in both cases but we'll
see what happens in fact she may say
that you know one should go against the
other we don't know but i think it'll be
interesting to see
at the end of the day what she does and
how she helps
would in terms of the prosecution of
this particular case
yeah and pro-hawk vichai is just a fancy
word that we lawyers use when
when someone comes from a different
county in uh i i may go and practice a
case with brian dunn for example where
he is
it's very common amongst defense
attorneys not so much for prosecutors
we've seen it in the george floyd case
looks like we're going to see it here in
the lorry vallo case brian terry thank
you for joining us
and thank you for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you